the New England Patriots have lost two
in a row and they are literally and
figuratively on to Cincinnati the
Bengals are up next in Cincinnati it was
that blowout loss to the Chiefs in
September of 2014 that caused Bill
Belichick to coin that famous phrase it
was a Sunday night
back when the Bengals were good
Cincinnati came to New England and New
England destroyed them we keep waiting
for that now we've seen two straight
loss as a team that was ten and one
crisp yeah two straight losses the
inability to get it done yesterday
against the Chiefs are they done are the
Patriots done they're not done they're
not and I'm never gonna count the
Patriots out you know they're just it's
what would it take for you to say
they're done um losing the Bengals yes
it would yes if they lost the Bengals
this week I would go yep it's over there
you have no chance of making a run in
the AFC playoff sub but you know they're
just a they're a coaching staff that's
too smart they're too creative
you know Brady still too smart and too
good to wear if they can just get Nikhil
Harry moved along in this offense and
Mohamed Sanu totally healthy and of
course with Julian Edelman that I always
have belief that they're gonna find the
right formula for their football team
now you know the issue is yes Brady's
not as good as he's been you know he's
42
the offensive line I think is really the
big thing that scares me more than
anything whether it's pass protection or
the inability to control the line of
scrimmage in the run game and Mike to me
the big thing is they know it which is
weird we're in the middle of December
it's very weird that we're talking about
the Patriots and a work in progress with
anything in December but I think they
know you know calling to trick plays
like yesterday that Belichick
challenging a Sammy Watkins third down
catch where there was really no
clear-cut camera angle but challenging
it those little just Inklings showed me
that you know they realize like oh man
we can't blow this situation or we got
to take advantage of this right here we
so I you know I guess they're not it's
just weird that were questioning them
yeah I you know their schedule wasn't
good this year they dominated a very
poor schedule and now it's almost like I
don't know where to kind of put them in
the AFC as far as how good they really
are they still want the division because
the bills are only a game behind they do
have the Bengals on the road this week
than a Saturday home game against the
bills yeah
I won't be weak 17 the dolphins come to
town and you know hey what would Brian
Flores love o to do I would if he could
be if he could be the fly in the
ointment right the wrench in the gears
that keeps the Patriots from winning the
division or clinching a bye and they
have had a bye
every year since 2010 yes and they've
been in the AFC Championship game every
year since 2011 and it really is in
question now and and you do have to
wonder it's not like we're gonna we're
gonna throw dirt on the Patriots but
what we saw yesterday was stunning yeah
in the aftermath of the loss to the
Texans right and we see those plays
where Tom Brady just kind of bails out
and throws the ball and I look the guy
has played for 20 years he's 42
he has young strong large fast men
chasing him I can understand his
reluctance to get hit together 12 times
against the Texans
six more times against the Chiefs and at
some point your self-preservation gene
has to kick it up but that even that
last throw how many times have we seen a
quarterback stand in there and know that
hits coming but want to deliver the most
accurate throw possible with the game on
the line not the falling away wing and a
prayer
hope my guy can get it out no you stand
there and deliver it and you know you're
gonna take the hit yeah didn't stand
there - and again I wouldn't either I
would never do it once though he's been
order for 20 years but when I see that
it just makes me think how close is
father time yeah - taking little pieces
of evidence yes that's really all it is
you're exactly right and there was a
handful of plays in the Houston Texans
game - and again when you're under
duress you're gonna be flinchy but
there's been little pieces here and
there of a lot of games with the New
England Patriots this year where yeah
maybe there's a guy open he aggressively
flinches in the pocket cuz he thinks the
packets about to collapse and then you
know when he does gather himself the
guy's not open anymore and you know
again they are a work in progress
totally on the offensive side of the
ball I'm not sure they can get it
together I know that staff will continue
to tinker and work with it Brady still
is dangerous his arm is still really
good there's no doubt about that there's
just so much pressure on their defense
and special teams right now to win games
I mean it's unbelievable really you know
they're their first scoring tribe that
happened - let's not forget because a -
big pass interference cause that's how
they got the ball down the field so even
you know and some of their successful
drives yesterday it was you know yeah
mistakes by the Kansas City Chiefs or
whatever as having said all that they
had chances to win the football game and
got unlucky I mean that game was crazy
where the Chiefs dominated the game and
you go man the Chiefs should be winning
like 30 33 to 10 right now and then you
went from men New England got screwed
over in two calls they'd be won in this
football game
so even when they're floundering they
still find ways to be a pain in your ass
Tom Brady was on WEEI this morning he
said he didn't get a ton of sleep last
night anxious to get in there get back
to work this morning and he also
addressed that issue of getting Ono
being on the wrong end of the
officiating calls yeah not getting booed
but but having those two calls that we
talked about he said when you play
sports long enough I think sometimes
you're the recipient of things that go
your way and you're on the other side of
it too for me I don't think too much
about it I wish it would go away
unfortunately they didn't it doesn't
take away from when you watch the game
all the different things we had in our
control that I wish we could have done
right better so well you don't make
excuses for them because you know
there's gonna be games where it happens
for you right it's gonna be games where
it happens against you I'm gonna play
well enough that you win even when it
happens against you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports